welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and with
spider-man far from home now making its
way across the web after it's released
digitally in the US this week I thought
I'd go through the film with a
fine-tooth comb and point out all the
times that Mysterio was in the
background ever seen if you checked out
my everytime Pennywise was hidden in the
background of his scene you know I
pointed out the appearance of Mysterio
in that as a little bit of trivia and
after re-watching the movie I noticed
the character or rather his group a
couple more times throughout I was
putting together this video and then the
worst thing in the world happened new
rock stars dropped one and all my work
was undone so just to make sure you get
an extra bang for your buck I'm going to
be explaining all of the times that we
had clues that everything was also an
illusion there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the movie yet then I highly
suggest that you turn off now if the
title and introduction hasn't already
ruined everything look it's the heavy
spoilers show what are you expecting
anyway huge thank you for quick in this
video now let's get into my breakdown of
every time that Mysterio was hidden in
the background of a scene okay so first
things first in far from home Mysterio
is revealed to be a group or rather gang
of disgruntled stark employees that at
some point or another had their hard
work and inventions cast aside because
of Tony Stark's ego the group are all
experts in their fields and all come
together as one to make a cohesive unit
that can perfectly betray illusions
there are storytellers market
researchers cold-call ISM guessing
scientists and actors that all help to
flesh out the illusions of Mysterio in
order to make them feel more believable
the first big appearance of Jake
Gyllenhaal actually comes way before he
meets spider-man in the under
Laird at about the 18 minute and 15
second mark right before Peter goes to
buy the Black Dahlia necklace for MJ
well the shot is solely focused on Peter
in the background to the left hand side
we can in fact see Mysterio standing
there watching him it's a blink and
you'll miss it moment that shows that
the villain was always in the area
planning for the water elemental attack
and he's not alone throughout the scene
a couple more of the group including
Goodman walks behind MJ in Pierre as
they stroll along the canal we like to
see in the movie that Goodman is the
storyteller of the group that writes a
narrative and events of things that
happen and hopefully Sony are getting
this guy right now to work on spider-man
3 because yeah I don't really have much
faith don't at me anyway there's also an
image of a blonde woman that looks
rather distinctive and we see her pop up
later in the movie as part of the
Mysterio so it seems like she's also
checking things out now I've seen people
say that this means that they were
stalking Peter the entire time and I've
kind of went back and forth on her quite
a bit there's actually two ways of
looking at these appearances either they
knew that Peter was there and selected
Venice as a place to pull off the
attacks so that they could get the Edith
glasses which is the cam band currently
in or they didn't know that the
character was there and while carrying
out the attack anyway and he just
happened to stumble across it now let me
know what you think in the comments
below but there's also several points in
the film in which we can see that
everything is all an illusion the first
one comes during the water attack in
which Peter is punched full force by
Hydra man but if you slow down the
footage and look really really closely
you'll notice that when Peter is first
hit and also a section of the bridge
gets destroyed
it doesn't actually get wet it just
explodes a bit and then the water from
the canal rising up comes and that's
what soaks everything rather than the
blast from the punch interesting right
well is also another subtle hint that
Mysterio isn't everything that he says
he is when Peters on the roof after
being completely shut down by Nick Fury
aka Talos during the scene Mysterio
flies in front of him to talk to him but
in hindsight we know that you can't fly
and this isn't actually the
so how does he end up sat next to Pierre
when the to go to talk well as Peter
talks you will notice at the camera pans
from a doorway behind him which also
mimics someone walking from the back to
sit next to Pierre and then Mysterio
joins him so I believe that Mysterio was
hidden at this point then snuck behind
him from a doorway and sat on the ledge
which is where the two illusions came
together allowing him to sit down
another big hint that everything is all
an illusion comes when Peter is fighting
the fire elemental and Nick Fury and
Maria hill arrive at the scene in their
jeeps during the attack there's a brief
moment where one of Mysterio's hand
laser beam dr. strange thingies hits the
car but instead of causing it to explode
or be melted all we see are bullet holes
in the windshield this clearly comes
from a drone and is in fact them just
firing at the car in order to make it
stop it's a nice little hint early on
that really is a blank in your missive
moment that showcases just how much of
an illusion everything was we also see
Peter land on a car which is badly
busted up and this is actually the one
that he and Mysterio disguises Nick Fury
arrived in which explains why the seat
belt didn't work in addition to this
Nick Fury also refers to earth as your
world when talking to Peter and we hear
him and Maria Hill discussing creature
in one of their conversations which lets
you know that they too may not be what
they seem
Nick also hates the thought of Captain
Marvel being brought up so yeah he's
just scroll the clues were all there
overall it laces the film with a lot
more to it and shows just how smart
Marvel really are when it comes to
making movies obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on these reveals and if
there's anything that I missed and make
sure you leave it in the comment section
below if you want to see my breakdown of
every time that Pennywise was in the
background of a scene a bit chapter one
into that make sure you check out that
video after this I'll link it at the end
so all you have to do is click it sit
back and relax if you want to come talk
to me about movies TV shows games and
comic books and you can follow me on
Twitter a definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this also just
wanna let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of spider-man far from
home on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on these appear and
is in the comment section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15 then the blur will be
shipped out from then to forget surprise
it's the best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]